droghe che bello come primo my life is
your life la mia vita è la tua vita è
bellissimo il primo livello vedere
questo cielo azzurro scusate ragazzi se
solo partito così però si vede no per
curiosità ma che io quando apro happy
with ragazzi e benvenuti avessero video
sono fa vigenti ed oggi siamo sul 96 e
jimi episodi di aprile all effetto
ragazzi sono partiti con drag che questo
bellissimo livello che consiglio a tutti
più bello infatti giocato tante volte
proprio dalla ge perché la gente
apprezza altro livello ragazzi che
volevo provare you'll never win che
questo tipo pensa che io risata malvagia
dopo sei la persona più perfida la terra
zio va temi vedere quanto in realtà è
impossibile questo livello perché non
credo che sia ma sono con la b ma posso
staccarmi oddio calmo zio che calmo
oddio dalla parti ormai sbagliato lato
frate ecco prefetto ma che cosa sta
facendo lì preciso
ragazzo tizio qua e in capra e incapace
è un incapace perfetto no cos'è a
volteggio a che ci sta che culo no
dall'altra parte signora latrava
bravissimo o no no ti uccido la famiglia
è devi entrare nel calo vedi il cannone
non quello che te fumi ed è rientrarci
le bravo ok però non ho capito dove
dovremmo andare
niente sonoro è andato più avanti prima
going for the moon o dove morì a thing
il cugino me ne frega delle vanzo che
sai che ti potrei ridurre così luke noto
lo dico a voi ragazzi visto che ho fatto
questa incredibile bellissima figura
giocando un livello che porca eva non so
riuscito manco a cominciare potete
togliere la musichetta e mi fa cagare
grazie presso space così perché libero è
che ho cliccato a caso del red min già
questo sarebbe omincia cervello mi già
pelato ragazzi preso spesso salvo che il
cassetto nova serio ragazze quando mi
ferma guarda lo schermo come mai sta
cosa guarda quanti gnocco è un livello
bellissimo complimenti sei un ninja
proprio capace la cosa che non ho capito
ragazzi dove devo andare io posso sotto
le cose non ingannano oyeah a faccia
parte della canzone now jan von driver
baxi zio non mi devi spiegare come
giocare ai platform gaming ultra hd ps4
gesù cristo affetto sono bravo sono mi
già incredibile sono bravo io a fare
l'in giace una nuvola che mi segue e che
cazzo la nuvola di fantozzi
cioè mi fate un livello così figo con un
ninja che si gira guarda lo schermo è
dura cinque secondi a questa è una demo
o scusami allora non volevo farti deball
la palla cosa che molti non hanno nuovi
la palla fino al gol
se lo farà a devo anche figlio quindi va
tutto in cliccato è la madonna che
figata porta la palla qui per vincere va
bene zio tranquilli tanto sembra un
cocktail coi coso rate il problema non è
che devo portare la palla lì il problema
è chi è che sta attirando sulla palla
così è magia nera
queste rovine quando ero piccolo per
vincere quando mettemmo in un euro e che
usciva la pallina di mandarla nel
buchino eccoli i centrali buy e proprio
lì erano altri tempi e salvaguardano da
questo livello non è per in loop che
cazzo penso di parlarsi only proprio
infinis di smat perfetto subito poco
subito salvime ma posso cominciare o e
siamo già partiti a devo resistere alle
spalle la prima lo prese in faccia
preciso devo sopravvivere alle spade che
arrivano per poi che si apre la l'uscita
mite impossibile so troppe ragazze o
decisore sociale quella dopo cia faccio
quella dopo camere e vabbè troppe o coro
fear culetto
lo scriva tanto mi esce mi sta uscendo
un pene dalla schiena non so perché anzi
o sei vivo il che è un miracolo quindi i
beni di non morire mentre c'è chi di
salire dai zio hai vinto caso sarebbe
stato tragico non vincere una volta
arrivati fa male fisioterapista cinque
minuti è risolto tutto
la palla della morte quella di primera
solo la palla adesso passiamo la palla
della morte che mi sembra più cazzuto a
è un tritatutto three tamburi e titta
zuk street ananas mitridate anche un
hayter nokia rileverà che non è non si
creda che ho scassa i vetri posso fare
una domanda intelligente promesso quale
cazzo è il senso giusto livello a parte
tenere premuto il tasto destra
cosa devo fare io da neanche un livello
difficile un livello che esprime la tua
la difficoltà di happy meals in tutta la
sua sostanza cioè ma ha senso cavo
desistere sarà che questa facendo quella
sta cagando possiamo andare alla fine
che veramente mi sta scadendo lo yogurt
in frigo fava è pià scusatelo arriva la
minchia veramente stavo perdendo la mia
vita e la mia anima il suo livello
schifoso gaylord che ha fatto suo
livello si chiama gaylord complimenti
impulsivo il 50 per cento blu perché per
lui che ci ha razzismo contro il rosso
il verde 92 potere tributo a corona de
sanghe rosso prima non
perché tanto c'è luke questo centro gli
ho chiesto livello non capito che è un
import mustard ha così poi finito il
livello cioè non puoi andare a sinistra
sono cadine nell'oltre verso non c'è un
cazzo jean luc come sai giornata di
merda
e anche io non me la posso molto bene
però in compenso vinto l'importante è
vincere che poi fotte sega crazy grampa
non lo passo che sarebbe non sa già che
giusto benvenuto a nonno pazzo e
bellissimo che c'è che sa con una gamba
sola e valli indietro c'è manco michael
jackson
ma cosa devo fare spacek il ma spacey
non fa un cazzo quindi space uguale non
fa un cazzo
anzi agoglia così stessa roba
dove devo andare mentre fa il ballerino
fighissimo ciao zio l'ho mancato son
riuscito a mancarti pensa che genio fa
male questo qua è il nuovo tipo di
terapia e quella che ti mettono gli
spillini ecco questo la terapia nonno
shakti metà fra il cian e al naso e poi
fa la liposuzione fantastica anno questo
è morto quindi passo oltre
ecco adesso è morto forse forse altro ha
ucciso un folletto che non c'entravo
cazzo poverino anche questo è morta da
sola interfaccia in pendeva già in a chi
è tornata viva site dovresti togliere
però oddio scusa agli 8 dimenticato
perdonami no credo che faccia male sono
così convinto che sto bambino non soffra
però soffre che giusto presentimento
strano no adesso voi mi spiegate come
come come perché ci sono rimaste solo le
mani è perché funziona ancora
cosa sta succedendo per quale motivo
funzionava ciò solo le mani zio ma come
è possibile fare ragazzi io so io più
gioca e più divento strano io non il
gioco di vento strano proprio io dove
c'era il cervello il cuore però
sopravvivi due ce l'hai nel polso 90 per
cento impossible questo dovrei riuscire
a farlo senza problemi si spera almeno
questo perfetto e non ho visto problemi
cento dovrei aver vinto è la madonna
quanto e violento o oddio il cazzo vero
allora ho capito ma va bene ok
importante vincere non è partecipare
importante vincere playing the piano
veramente questo è un piano particolare
ceppo bol d'or e mi fa dopo ragazzi mi è
venuta l'idea del secolo remix
[Musica]
bellissimo è geniale ragazzi sono un
arrangiatore nato quindi non faccio il
dj operato e gabry ponte favi ponte
rogio exter speciale breve finito beh
livello
oddio ma è un origami qualcuno sta
godendo dietro no ricami raga ma non è
che si sono sbagliati era questo qua a
livello delle droghe probabilmente si è
bene ragazzi non ho capito il senso di
sta roba però per l'amor di dio e perciò
kenny ces times al quale motivo c'è che
i suoi personaggi soft park che cazzo
sto comandando un nuovo afro da barba
con le gambe che si muove e io nella mia
vita non ho capito che sto facendo
invece di giocarsi cacate ex quello di
angry birds geste a fermi che traduco
huge stemma sarebbe io ti amo z cv e sta
chiedendo se c'è qualcuno che si chiama
b e dum dum io mio amico pozzo tasta
jenner
ok perfetto grazie che è finito a
livello perché non potevo più tra due
però la capra era [ __ ] la capra figata
ragazzi facciamo un paio di miei livelli
come al solito alla fine facciamo tipo
fa vj challenge perché ho visto che è
tra i più votati ma non avevo ancora
giocato tra l'altro suo livello deve
essere tipo minchia sto facendo cielo
sto prendendo tv con l'arpione cosa
impossibile
grazie mi tecnica fa posto a livello
impossibile tanto c'è il green screen si
posso tranquillamente mettere foto di
pony che che si uccidono dietro di
sfondo
eva biasi stronzo vivo no ma non ci
voglio credere a regate cazzone livello
è ma fermi
l'avevo fatta ok piano
ho vinto ho vinto non ci posso avere
sono rimasto in una posizione che
veramente la mia vita adesso ha un senso
però veramente figo d'accordo ragazzi è
stato non lo so perché ogni volta che
giocare più mi viene mal di testa però
no forse anzi credo di aver capito
meglio così ragazzi concluso cui
episodio è stato veramente figo ma per
l'amor di dio adesso nei commenti mi
scrivete che cazzo è staro cos'è spiega
sono io sono più bello io di questo
credo è più o meno volte no però dipende
dai giorni ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto siamo quasi arrivati al
centesimo episodio bombardate lo delight
episode anche il prossimo dovrà essere
pignoli laica perché voglio vedere che
ci tenete che ci arriviamo al centesimo
un giorno vi spiegherò che cosa voglio
fare per il centesimo episodio ma vi
terrò sulle spine a tal punto da non
dirvelo mai come se questo video risulta
solo momento è un mi piace anche a
pagani facebook e come è ridotta tales
chiziane solisti di scrittrici mi davano
prossimo video ragazzi